as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on meetup when the
recording's ready
i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today dr jags is an applied
mathematician and data scientist with
more than 10 years of experience in
building software software and systems
in his current role at wytronics llc
jags develops deep learning computer
vision systems and algorithms for
railroad safety and operations
he also works with researchers at iit
chicago in developing open source
quasi-monte carlo software
today
feel free to ask questions throughout
the talk you can
mute yourselves or use the raise hand
feature on zoom
or you can put your question in chat and
i will interrupt jags as as they come up
uh pass it over to you
well
thank you rebecca thanks for the
introduction
and also thank you for the opportunity
to talk about it
and also before starting i would like to
thank my employer to
authorize me to share some of the
content that i'm going to talk about
today
okay with that let me start
i want to share just the powerpoint
okay can you see my screen
yep you can see it
okay is that rebecca i said good no the
powerpoint
yeah we can see it
it's not in presenter mode but but
that's fine
[Music]
okay i think it should be good now
yep now it is okay
okay thank you so i'm today i'm going to
talk about uh the project that we are
working uh quite honest
uh for this railroad crossing inspection
uh but uh this is one of the very good
example of deep learning and computer
vision techniques uh so
uh before uh
before i talk about how we are doing it
i'm going to introduce the kind of
problem
uh basically what we are dealing with uh
provide some introduction and then try
to establish uh
some prerequisites for like deeply
neural networks and basically
convolutional networks and try to
provide some of the examples
typically used for this kind of problems
and then uh i will try to talk about
like maybe a simpler solutions and more
complex solutions and then
then i will try to show some of the
examples uh
from my uh
from our work actually
uh so with that said uh
yeah as rebecca mentioned please feel
free to stop me uh
consider this is a more like a
high-level introductory kind of thing
more like a survey and with uh in the
context of the
problem okay
so
here if you see uh
okay here if you see the
uh
in united states like there are like
more than 128 000 railroad crossings and
about that like one third of them have
gates and with the flashing lights there
are many crossing still doesn't have a
game even with the especially with the
gates there are a lot of accidents
happen and
basically there are a lot of petrol it
is happen
so these crossings uh are pretty much
automatically activated
uh based on uh how the train is
approaching and how fast uh so there are
some circuitry that uh identifies the
moment the train comes closer to the
crossing so there is a interactive
circuit uh that is built for example
this is a crossing side
here is the crossing i am showing so
there is a circuitry here and that it
extends all the way towards back in the
tracks and that identifies the
incoming train and this gates gets
activated right so these are all some of
the crossings that you might have seen
uh yeah and i'm going to explain about
the different kind of crossing different
uh parts of the crossing that that makes
all those things make it work
right so
right so basically that there are some
also mentioned there are some crossings
especially in the urban areas like if
you are going to the chicago especially
the closer to the suburban areas those
traffic lights also link to the traffic
lights so they work with uh based on the
basically the train is coming especially
you might have seen in the metro client
the train is coming that the traffic
lights also go gets activated and that
will uh basically
create the red light to stop the traffic
that's what we need
so here is drag right so the crossings
you know in a typical crossings right
you have a mask lights and this is
called the cantilever lights basically
the lights that is
extended over the over the road and this
is called the mast light right and there
are the the there are different kinds of
uh cross uh gates it's controlled two
two quad stands for two quadrant or four
quadrant depending on the size of the
road and uh uh
how basically high traffic areas that
the either they use like two gates or
four gates i think i will have some
examples to show about that
right the requirement is i think the
gates uh here says before 15 20 seconds
before the um the train reaches the
crossing uh the gates must be fully down
right and also if you are past if you
already went through different crossings
you would have seen the
basically the the lights blinking so uh
this is called wikibak and i think the
modern uh ones have these kind of pairs
they they go on and off alternatively to
simulate this kind of effect where this
in the in the olden days they used to
swing so to create that effect
right so basically there are many
requirements i think that that was all
governed by this called federal railroad
administration and they have mentioned
how the traffic what all the
requirements for this traffic uh
basically uh
how far the gate should extend and what
are the requirements for the gates and
what is the what is the frequency these
slides should flash there are many
requirements
right so the thing is that the problem
that we are trying to solve right so i
talked about the crossings that what we
are trying to solve is especially my
employer strengthens always
how to automate
using
this
artificial intelligence how to automate
this crossing inspection
to work with a human so
to help
uh basically add multiple sentences
probably that's the right word to say to
argument to make this uh
inspection um uh basically
basically they can reduce the interval
or maybe help in the
inspection and maybe more documentation
kind of systems right so basically to
help and enable so that the people can
work more effectively right that's
that's the kind of our goal right so uh
the thing is that i mentioned like two
quad four parts and maybe i'll show some
examples right so these gates make sure
the less traffic areas the the four
gates they they make they also block the
exit side so that
you might have seen some people passing
through the crossings those kind of
things should be avoided so another
thing the important part about this
crossing is you can see this is the sign
if there is a problem right the the
people who have to call this number
right and here it has given for example
this mpta this is the railroad name and
this is the basically the crossing id
this is the number you caught right so
basically most of the time right now
today the something is fails people call
it actually right so we are trying to
see okay
how we can
if possible
report before somebody informs it a lot
of times i don't know
in busy life i don't know how many
people take time to really
go and inform people right in this kind
of cases how we can automate
okay so that is a kind of uh
problem that we are trying to solve
right here i'm showing the the what i
talked about the two quad and fourth
quad gate side if you've seen so this is
the four four quadrant gate if you see
like the the
there are gates that are uh blocking
both in entry and exit side like that so
especially in the busy areas right and
also there are some residential areas
where they don't want to have the
so basically the residents they don't
want this uh the locomotives to blowing
hard so that kind of quiet areas they
they put in these kind of things and
some cases right they will have to avoid
people
running through it they will have a
media right so to block that one so
that's the kind of uh
setup they will have depending on the
traffic different depending on the uh
basically uh see almost every crossing
is pretty much unique right based on how
the road crosses the
tracks and how many tracks are there
like there are many things changes from
one one crossing to other classes that's
the idea of the two quadrant
right
and uh having said that let me go to the
uh yeah so i talked about the inspection
right so as part of this inspection this
is a big manual
the the railroad companies uh they have
to send a personal to inspect these
crossings like a monthly quarterly and
annually and basically the quarterly
inspections are a little bit lighter and
sorry the monthly inspections are little
bit brighter and the quarterly annual
expressions are much more rigorous to
make sure everything works fine as you
can see these crossings have to work in
all weather conditions throughout the
year
basically the failure has to be so low
so they they
this is and also this any of these
crossing failures and that leads to any
of this
accident this is a big uh legal and pr
issue so the writers take a lot of time
and effort to make sure these crossings
functions very well right so some of the
requirements for example uh and again uh
as i mentioned um i am part of this team
and my at my work my team
and the product managers they did
extensive research and how to what are
the things we can do right what are the
things possible within the kind of setup
system we have these are all the kind of
the classes from that inspection manual
we figured out right for example to
check for like flashing lights the the
the voltage based on that so using a how
much we can do about these things and
then the how the gate arm and the gate
mechanism so the gate mechanism is the
one that is where the gate is attached
to there is electric motor that is
operating this one and this warning
system these are like high level thing
and then the individual
in particular like when you are
inspecting how the individual gate arms
are working and the the the mass like
whether it's flashing or flashing at the
right frequency intervals right uh they
typically flash from like 30 to 60
um
60 per minute right so so
that's the kind of record they they want
to make sure that it's running that and
then uh basically whether the light
pairs are working fine and then the
warning time i mentioned i mentioned so
there is certain time right so the
before the locomotive starts you might
have seen the the lights start
blinking and then the the build sound
starts coming right so that that starts
and then when the when the warning
started then the gates start coming down
there is like a choreographed kind of
activity that happens so all those
things are there are some huge
requirements so they have to check it so
what they do now is these people go
and they
there is a circuitry on the side of the
thing maybe i will show some of the
images and they're going to activate
those things manually and then check
whether all those things are working
it's pretty manual as i mentioned
in the island where the the road and the
track meets there's a circuitry that
extends all the way to back depending on
the speed of the locomotive for example
right like up to 2000 feet not up to two
typically like if it is a seventy miles
per hour or uh
locomotive running then basically up to
two thousand feet they have to before
that the circuit should be installed and
then based on how fast train is coming
that inductance of the circuit uh
changes that helps them to identify what
what speed the locomotive is coming
right if the locomotive is running slow
then the lights also based on the speed
they will they will start
activating
that 15 20 seconds
right so if it is running really slow
you don't want to activate much i have
time like people get impatient with the
class all those things so the people how
to manually check all those things
okay
so
basically the the thing is as i
mentioned so this is very important but
thing is this is a really a costly work
and it is a highly
labor intensive right so
because of that
they have to employ a lot of people to
go on to inspect and also as you know
because it's a manual inspection there
are something could possibly be missed
right so that's where we are trying to
see how much we can uh help in uh
augmenting it
okay so
having said that i thought i will show
one crossing to understand little bit uh
better right so here i have opened uh
one crossing here
hopefully you can see my screen
so this crossing uh uh nearby where i
live this is called the deal road in
nepal like you can you can see this
crossing
yeah before i jump into that i don't
know if anybody has any questions uh i'm
just going to show our real crossing
here
so if you see this crossing right so
this is like a one track crossing here
like i mentioned this is a median
and we have a cantilever lights and you
can see that there are one pair here one
pair here right and there is a the huge
gate arm like to block these two lanes
right and there is the most lights here
all right and then i mentioned so this
is there is a motor mechanism here and
there's a counterbalance
right
we have that kind of setup
and then you can go here a little bit
and then you can see those
warning signs
okay
so you can see that the one that i
talked about the kind of warning signs
down though
this is like the typical crossing so
yep so to control all those things you
can see there is a circuitry this is
what they go and activate and do all
those manual inspections
right so yeah this is how the typical
crossing looks
uh let me go back to the presentation
yeah
so the
basically the
this is the example of a two two gates
under two cantilever lights kind of
setup
let's see right i i think that the the
kind of view right so
uh yeah the my my my company like
vitronics
they provide the remote monitoring
solutions to these railroad companies so
these cameras are installed uh in the
like the outward facing and they can see
this kind of view
right so this is kind of thing so uh
there are some videos i think i don't
know maybe i'll give the links better
people want to watch this kind of
outdoor view right so
all those crossings right again
um anna
maria is asking uh if you collect the
data from sensors in real time
yep yep real time so uh so the the
solution the way the way it works is we
uh these uh boxes are installed on the
locomotives they can collect pretty much
all the signals there so the biggest
innovation the vitronics brought into
this business is previously they used to
have a recorder that records all the
data something
something accident happens like the
black box kind of thing in the airplanes
then only they go and look at this
recording so my micron vitronics what
they you know the innovation is they
pretty much in real time upload to the
cloud and the customers can watch pretty
much what is happening in the
locomotives and then they can track
so right now you can do all sorts of
remote basically all sorts of remote
monitoring stuff you can do right now
that we are trying to provide this
pretty much real time video they can
watch the how the crews are operating
and how the outward view is looking like
what i showed here
so you could you could see this view
pretty much in real time
yeah hopefully i answer your question uh
yeah pretty much everything is real time
so yeah here is another thing i showed
you right so
basically this is how this is the
engineer called locomotive engineer so
here is the camera that is looking
outward i took it from youtube
there are plenty of examples in youtube
so they this is the way you see it and
then you can see this is the road number
so the locomotive they called the asset
and id for the the railroad companies
that to track it and then this is this
is the way the engineer side i think
this is where the camera is installed
okay so now let's go to it yeah so what
we are trying to do is using those
outward camera how much we can monitor
automate and monitor every time here is
something i want to say why this problem
is really challenging first of all this
has to work 24 7 it has to work all the
time all weather conditions so
it has to work all the time one good
thing about this because this is a
locomotive like a headlight in our car
uh there is a light
facing outward they can
right nighttime it eliminates the the
gates so that's the reason we could
still work on even night times but with
the visibility changes i will have some
examples to talk about another big
challenge is
let's say this is the track and the not
depending on the road how they cross it
there's a crossing angle right sometimes
if you think of this is the way the gate
is from here if your locomotive is here
the gate is pretty much basically the
the gate actual gate will be hiding
behind that motor mechanism that i
showed
so sometimes so basically when you are
we have outward facing camera when
you're running coming from here you
might not be able to see the gate all
the time
so
the reason i'm saying is some people
think okay why can't you just take one
image and just do all those verification
right so it is not that a simple problem
because this has to work all kind of
variations different kind of processing
that's a problem right and also uh as i
mentioned we also need to check the
whether the lights are flashing which
for which you definitely need a video
right that's that's the kind of thing so
another advantage of because we have a
video we could we could uh basically
uh
accumulate we
output from different frames then you
can do in sample to get improve your
overall accuracy that's a another reason
why we are doing much more sophisticated
solutions than simple taking one image
right
so now let's go to yeah okay i hope you
introduced enough talked about enough
over the class it looks like we spent
already close to 30 minutes now so now
let's get into the actual how we are
going to solve this problem right so
what we are trying to do is the deep
learning rate we are just using the
outward camera and let's see how much we
can do out of that traditionally i think
people if you are
already working in this computer version
you may have heard this kind of car hog
kind of term this is how
people used to do the computer vision
object detection and verification kind
of stuff previously but after this deep
learning become really popular right so
that deep learning meaning like we apply
user deep neural networks to solve this
problem right so you give an input you
do extraction and then it learns and
gives you output so the biggest
challenge is getting the data and
choosing the right architecture pretty
much it's just simply placed upon
traditionally we used to get features
and then train a network so
within with the latest uh
innovations and the the developments and
the basically availability of the more
and more powerful gpus this is possible
now previously this this was not
possible because we did not have enough
uh computing power i think people who
are working in this domain are already
pretty much familiar with that
uh okay so i took some of these examples
uh i took a lot of stuff liberally from
this cs231 course from stanford course
right so they have given a lot of nice
introductions about about the
classification segmentation object
detection
segmentation
difference between
segmentation classification so
what we are talking about is in our
problem we are trying to locate these
gates and then verify its status that's
why we are trying to do that
right in the object deduction right and
then and again in the last six seven
years that a lot of developments happen
so the in a high level right they have
like a two stage object direction or one
stage object direction that's the kind
of solutions available and then the the
faster ascii and then that's that's kind
of revolutionized this object direction
there are so many variations right there
are so many things available and then
the one stage direction the yellow and
the ssd this is kind of the popularly
available well researched and well
documented uh object reduction solutions
are available
right so as i mentioned like the single
stage one all that it does is it just
takes the input and tries to give you
just simply output what is the location
like basically where this object is
there you are trying to detect okay here
is a dog and then what is the
coordinates that's what we are trying to
determine that's a one stage
and uh yeah so this one stitch
directions depends on the anchor boxes
basically you try to overlay different
uh shapes and aspects of these boxes and
try to detect it right
uh yeah i think yeah that's the kind of
thing mainly the the anchor boxes and uh
those kind of things are biggest
challenges for real estate so the two
stage what it does is it has a
the the
the object deductions works with the
feature right the feature extraction
right and then one stage detectors
typically just classify it the two stage
directors they get a feature extraction
and then then do a second develop
classification so they they kind of the
one bigger advantage is these kind of
architectures are used to be typically
much more accurate than the one stage uh
but i think with the recent more and
more developments i think also is also
trying to break the two stages
right with that said so i'm going to
little bit dive into more about one
state especially called
[Music]
yeah okay okay so sorry about that so
that um so i'm going to talk about a
little bit about the yolo so this one
especially i think that this kind of
architects are popular recently because
they are giving much better accuracy and
also this yolo comes with the different
level of levels of uh
computational complexity like starting
with nano small medium large so you
could you could have one architecture
and you could deploy it either on a big
gpu are all the way to the lightweight
mobile devices right so that's one of
the advantages and there are a lot of
community support so that's why
the yolo is really popular nowadays so
kind of going to talk about in this
context how this could be useful for our
kind of problems
all right so the the yolo architecture
right it has a like mission that there's
a backbone the to extract the features
and there is something called the neck
right
that is basically the path aggregation
network and then so basically this kind
of architectures are used so previously
they had like a one feature extraction
and tried to classify it the problem
with was
depending on the how the anchors was
chosen they used to work with only
typical if the
typical sizes of objects
so this kind of this
basically this up sampling and these
things right it helps to work with the
different sizes of objects right that's
that's the kind of architecture
okay now let's go this is little bit
more sophisticated view of that
architecture previously we saw here
all right here it gives you more
realistic basically
using this uh different
parts of this network
right so the basically the
the these networks right once you have
this architecture this is kind of lost
you are trying to this is kind of lost
function we are trying to
uh optimize using this uh the
optimization to get
to train our model so i'm just giving
you a quick glance up basically the
overall losses depends on how the
objects are classified and what's the
confidence and then this is
this is the complete iou to get that one
right so the so these are all the kind
of
loss functions we have
so yeah here a little bit more i think
if we have time we'll come back but
basically pretty much these networks are
like have a one config file you could
configure different kinds of uh
as i mentioned small medium large of
network
right so they have the bottom line
bottleneck like cross stage partial
networks so they they you can stack
depending on
how sophisticated basically how much
capacity you you want in your network
right so yeah the some of the hyper
parameters right i mean
this domain you know
not only you however you have the right
architecture and also you you may have
to optimize depending on your data
right so these are the kind of
hyper parameters available in this
particular family of uh objective action
models right you can these are different
kinds of augmentation features right
like the focal laws and
these models gain pretty much high
accuracy depending on how they augment
the data right so the whole data so all
those things are depending on
what kind of parameters so so basically
what i'm trying to say is uh depending
on the kind of data set you have like
in our application maybe this parameters
come differently but
depending on the application these
parameters will completely vary
okay so what we are trying to do is like
as i mentioned so for uh this problem we
are going to direct the object and then
look at it as a video view right we are
trying to verify it from multiple uh uh
multiple frame
so
yeah maybe before i go into the tracking
i don't know if anybody has any question
uh
there is there is any question maybe i
am going to show one example uh how this
object detection and tracking kind of
could work in our application
uh let's see
here is one example i
have hopefully you can see in my screen
all right you can see this is the kind
of crossing here it's a simple one and
also the the this lighting condition is
pretty good here right you could see
that the gate arm is because of the
angle right this angle is like about
maybe the 3250 kind of degree angle and
you could see this gates and then you
can see this light right this is the
kind of setup so this is kind of where
we we detect multiple objects and then
uh accumulate basically consolidate from
different frames and then try to make
one video level decision how they are
working
right so
yeah
here is one example right so here like
the the the next topic that we are going
to get into right once you directed
object so we need to track them across
multiple frames
let's get into this node
now okay
so
one one one one very good solution
available right now is uh it's called
deep shot so these
networks the way they do is they
they basically you detect the frame and
then feed into this network and then try
to kind of uh track from one prompt so
there are two three two aspects you use
basically the bounded boxes like i
mentioned here so you you take one
bounding box and then go to the next
frame how much overlap this box overlaps
with the previous prime you use the test
idea right and then
there are two two aspects it uses one is
how much overlap and how similar is from
one frame to other frames so that's the
kind of idea for this deep short kind of
network so they use uh i think the
internally the the kelvin filter is used
so to track this uh objects basically it
uses this
box center position under the aspect
ratio and the height right and then
these two are like the velocities of
these four parameters it tracks them and
then try to uh uh identify this object
between the multiple frames
right
so let's go to the uh
so as i mentioned yeah the same thing so
you you
the moment you see one object right here
let's say you you go all the way back
the object was never visible
i think in this video maybe it's all
available but yeah here you can't see so
at some point of frame the object enters
in and after some time the object
leaves the scene so all those things
will be tracked based on the two
criterion that i mentioned
so yeah here is little bit how they
calculate the the the basically the
losses and then the the distances and
then compute from one frame to other
point
uh so yeah here is one uh basically
algorithmic thing i depicted from the
paper so you you try to
basically try to add a new objects that
you enter the scene and then delete the
objects that uh that
once they leave the scene
right and then you have two computer
right the cost matrix and gas the cost
is like the iou map right and then the
the the gating is like how they they are
differing so those two parameters are
used
right so the using these two things you
can build a simple solution
but if you want to the there are there
are there are some problems with this
one
here uh
i think in our case we've seen as we go
here the we are in this case
our camera is moving right in this in
this kind of computer problem the object
is stationary but the camera is moving
so as we get closer the the angle that
we see these gates that the angle
changes
right so that
that brings a different kind of problem
they may not look similar
in certain frames
so
this because this is a two-stage
direction right you direct and then you
track
that they they may not work in all the
time so that is where we need uh let's
go to the
that is where you need a more like the
video level object detection so right
now uh
these two things work separately so
the more modern approaches are like the
mission what i talked about so far is
called the post processing methods so
the the more more basically the
effective one is like you you try to
like for example take a 3d convolution
right you take two frame frames one
frame to other frame so instead of doing
convolutions in a frame you do straight
over to video level right that's the
kind of point other thing is you take
detection and then use recurrent neural
networks and combine uh output from
multiple uh multiple frames and then
make one decision
and then even more sophisticated things
are optical flow methods so they they
they try to detect uh basically how much
the object moved from one frame to other
framework based on the lighting that is
all those things then they try to
estimate this optical flow using neural
networks and then try to track the
updates
so
as i understand i think these methods
are a little bit more complicated but
they seem to work better but i'm not
really much experimented but i'm saying
just this all kind of things
depending on the complexity of your
problem
so other thing approach is basically
the the
the object tracking that i mentioned so
they they working
separately like you direct and then
track the
maybe the much better approach is how to
do them together
right so here is another approach where
the kind of same network you try to do
the detection and tracking that's the
other one
so there is another solution available
probably this is where we will get into
the
demo so
as part of this google uh researchers
they developed this one where basically
you you do directions and then use this
lstm kind of networks and then try to
track from one frame to other
right so using this one so basically the
the the main advantage is you know in
one of my previous supply curves every
time you do a you do direct without
knowing what happened in the previous
prime right these things
they do a much better job uh because you
have a context here
right so
yeah the flow net is what i mentioned
like using this optical flow kind of
this kind of approaches
uh yeah okay so i talked about what are
the things that the thing right to
measure these things right so the model
detected one box and then what is the
ground truth right to measure those
things we use this kind of iou metrics
right and then how do we check those
kind of uh basically uh how much the
precision record is computed using this
thing so basically to measure the
performance you need to measure how much
the overlap is the result io threshold
and then
the confidence of how much the the
confidence of the object detection per
object
right uh
okay so before i get into this one uh if
any questions i can answer otherwise i
will try to show one example here
so as i mentioned the context rcn and
right so here
i have this code example here
so these networks right
let me bring this
so this context rcnn like if you want to
experiment this is part of this
tensorflow uh
object detection framework and here you
can see this is a
so uh uh
basically if you are
all that we need is that configure this
config file right these are all the kind
of parameters we have here like right in
this one and then
to train this network uh what we need to
do is like we need to give the
checkpoint basically the
uh if you want to retrain you we will
pick the one model that was already
trained by this uh
uh
using some open source data and then for
your uh your particular data set you
will use this as a seed and try to train
this one right so that that's the kind
of setup you have here what i have shown
is uh
like i took i took this as only
demonstrating here the the the inference
part here you can see
um
basically i have i have installed the
tensorflow
[Music]
i'm going to install the tensorflow
package here
so this brings all the uh
yep so it is installed here so then i'm
going to install the focal tools
all right so after all the setups are
done right
so this is the one the package that i
mentioned the google cloud
that our object detection the resistance
one
so i'm going to install this one
so
what i'm trying to demo here is uh so
for this context rcnn
so you we have
every frame we detect a feature and then
we try to uh give a additional the
context information in this case the
contact information is what is the
camera that took the video and what is
the time so based on the time
information it tries to keep this
context and then it remembers this in
the memory
so here uh let's see
it loads the model
yesterday
okay sorry maybe i missed something
okay so maybe there is something
everything here sorry about that
uh
so after this is installed okay so
maybe i can show that the code and then
maybe talk about that later so the model
is loaded so that i'm trying to show the
context here
so
for every image the that we are having
when we are feeding through the video
right we have the time stamp from one
frame to other frame so we are trying to
impart this time and then take this as
embedded feature and then the
the input is the the the object location
from the previous frame right and all
those things are fed here
and then we are going to run the
inference here
per image basis
so here uh basically the in this demo we
the the input as shown is without the
context and with context right
if you show here uh
here is what we done so this data set is
called the
uh the basically uh the to track the
animals at the night time right so
that's the kind of input here uh so this
is without any context so this one is
with the context basic meaning like in
the past frames if we directed this
object the model remembers this one
right so here in this case it was easy
it was directed here the the simpler
network failed to detect but the uh the
the context rcnn it was able to detect
again with much higher confidence
because it knows the past
so here are some of the examples we have
here
yeah so yeah that's the kind of thing i
want to show here so i i mean again as i
mentioned unfortunately i cannot use the
data set from my work so i'm trying to
show it from this open source data if
somebody wants to use
this is the way to go yeah
right
so yeah uh so here i have as i've shown
here is one one uh
example like with the good lighting
conditions as you can see all the things
everything you can see but here is
another example
you can see uh
hopefully you can see my video
here is one the kind of challenges we
have at the night basically the foggy
kind of setup here right
in this kind of situations you can see
still the model is able to detect and
then
as you can see this hundred is this
object id it's able to track and then
derive
right so there's a kind of challenge
here in this different kind of light the
writing conditions it has to work
uh
and other things is
basically
you have
as i mentioned so this is the kind of
angle this kind of angle but here you
can see this is like the the 60 degree
kind of angle so
i have this kind of nighttime setup
and here you have the the four quarter
lights with the night time so there may
be sometimes you have some kind of
abstraction inside so that kind of
setups we have
so the reason why i'm saying why it is
really such a challenging problem
so here is the like basically much wider
road basically the four gates at the
different locations almost every
crossing is kind of looks different
here again another one with the night
time again there is a damaged gate here
right
so this is kind of time this is the
evening time that kind of night uh
basically different kind of type so so
the model is able to learn and you're
detecting all those kind of changes so
here is another there's no kind of
situation we have to wear expected still
to work so this is kind of a troubled
condition where we are not able to
direct at all
right this is a night time with the snow
and this is how the gate arm is start
right so basically the
as part of this inspection what we are
trying to do is we are
getting this is expected this is a
failure case there has to be a real-time
honor we have to give to the
right so
yeah
would you be able to share a link to the
google collab you had earlier yep
so i think
i had another
let me put it
yeah i have another example i don't know
whether it is shared perfectly i will
share it probably if it is not
i had one more example to demo for the
so there is another computing
architecture for the uh uh
comparison to the the yolo that the
efficient did but i don't think we have
time i don't know whether we have time
to check it out other one that's other
alternating you have
right so
yeah so i was talking about the kind of
lighting conditions why this is a
challenging problem right so we are
expected to work all the time
okay
so
another thing is okay so we were talking
about um
another advantage of uh considering this
is a video problem rather than the frame
problem is
here i have listed the the kind of
object boxes here so this is like the
whole video
all the
objects detected are flattered here so
if it missed in one frame you could use
it to interpolate and then catch that
one so that's the kind of advantage we
have
with the considering this is a video
problem rather than a frame problem
right
yeah i think pretty much i covered the
important things that i want to talk
about it
if anybody has any questions i can go in
the uh
so basically in our kind of industrial
setup right so we we
we not only it's not a one time done
problem right i think these kind of
problems we continuously gather data and
then keep retraining it you have to take
and then
so that is the kind of implementation
kind of challenges so you collect the
data and then
label it and then
feed it to that one and then there is a
user feedback if there is if there is a
if there is a
basically failure you get some feedback
from the user and then use it to refine
the model
uh
yeah so
other things right what is this problem
right the sometimes you may not have
enough images for certain classes so
those kind of cases we do augmentation
right so the augmentation is something
like here is one example that i
copied from this year so basically you
change you take the image because the
same image you alter it and then feed to
the network so here in this case let's
say we are only getting the images only
in the daytime but nighttime or the
evening time little light conditions you
could transform the images to
accommodate with the little kind of
variations in those likes
uh jax a couple of questions um the club
notebook uh needs access
yes i will do that
[Music]
and then a question about how do you
select the features
uh so
i think i'm not sure what what you are
asking but in in this deep neural
network
you don't really choose the features
right you choose a backbone
right or and then the backbone
as you train the model it learns the
features and then the the second stage
where you classify it and
pick the objects
not sure if that is what you are asking
but
the feature selection we don't do here
the biggest challenge is you label it
for example here
uh sorry maybe
let me show here
these are all the human
human labeled one and then you train the
model to pick those things
did i answer your question sir
i will share try to share this
uh
in the meantime if anybody asks a
question
okay i'm trying to share this one also
now
okay yeah i think that's it
i think uh we
i have some more things to cover but i
don't know whether we have time here
so yep
any other question
okay well thank you jax for a really
thorough talk with lots of context and
covering a whole breath you basically
you know covered all of computer vision
there you know in an hour so yeah really
appreciated hearing your talk
uh just a reminder to everyone that this
is a monthly meet up and that we
typically meet uh the last thursday of
the month
so i think somebody asked how do you
how do you pick the
uh we pick the back
so basically like uh as i mentioned
depending on the complexity of the
problem right there may be a like
let's start with the simplest situation
right uh
if you are
if you don't have a lot of lighting
condition variations if you don't have a
lot of uh changes let's say you are
trying to detect a box in a within a
room only one kind of lighting
conditions then you don't need actually
really complicated models but if you
have the one that i showed this kind of
so many lighting condition variations
then
basically the the depth of the neural
networks you can pick let's say we pick
the yolo right the yolo has a different
uh levels of sophistication right
small medium
so
those things actually that
that particular one if you are picking
the yellow kind of thing they use that
the cross stage partial network that's
the back
but actually you could pick for example
the rest net 50 or rest net 100 that
kind of backbone also you can pick it up
so it depends on the sophistication of
the complexity of your problem maybe you
can pick from the very light weight to
the all the way to the complex
but how do you know whether
the model is sufficient value one thing
right i think
some of the pioneers in this field like
the andre karpati one of the thing he
mentions is if you are you should be
able to over fit within your data
if you are able to overfit that means
your monitor can land
right that's how you pick the backbone
hopefully i answered that question
uh thanks i think somebody
yeah
great um
well yeah we're we're about on the hour
um so
uh seems like most people here know each
other so if they have more questions
they can uh follow up with you
thank you everyone for attending
thank you